Wenn nur Wasser aus dem Auspuff kommt …
Man weiß es auch,
dass, wenn ich alleine fahre,
ich der Einzige bin, der C02 produziert.
Und [wenn] die ganze Welt
etwas lernen kann…
Unsere Wasserstoffproduktion in Bosbüll
ist eigentlich die Blaupause,
die Sie überall auf der Welt aufbauen können.
Und [wenn] sie auch stolz auf das sind,
was sie erreicht haben …
Das ist schon,
ja, genial eigentlich, dass wir das hier vor
Ort produzieren und nutzen können.
Dann sind wir ganz oben im Norden:
Deutschlands erstes Modellprojekt,
bei dem eine Region ohne
fossile Brennstoffe auskommen will
und voll auf Wasserstoff setzt.
Doch wie gut klappt das?
Und wie teuer ist das für die Bewohner?
Seit einigen Wochen fahren zwei Busse mit
Wasserstoff im Linieneinsatz.
Für das Projekt wurden
mehrere Tankstellen gebaut,
an denen auch Autos
Wasserstoff tanken können.
Und wie findet der Fahrer den neuen Bus?
Das Gute an dem Bus ist,
dass er geräuschlos fährt.
Man hört nur den Elektromotor
und man hört nur das Lenkgetriebe,
ansonsten ist Ruhe.
Wenn natürlich Fahrgäste im Bus sind,
kann man die Gespräche mithören.
Manchmal ist es nicht so schön,
aber man hört dann
irgendwann nicht mehr hin und achtet
dann eben auf andere Sachen im Bus –
wie zum Beispiel den Straßenverkehr.
Doch ist der Bus auch alltagstauglich?
Aktuell ist das Problem,
dass es manchmal
mit der Tankung schwierig ist.
Das heißt, dass der Bus
und die Tankanlage
nicht miteinander sprechen.
Das ist ein Software-Problem.
Das kann man lösen.
Mit ein paar Software-Updates
sollte das gelöst sein.
Das Herzstück des Wassersoff-Projekts.
Das ist hier unser Elektrolyseur.
Den muss ich einmal öffnen.
André Steinau hat das Modellprojekt
ins Leben gerufen.
Seine Firma betreibt den Elektrolyseur.
Mehrere Millionen Euro hat der gekostet.
In dem Container wird aus Wasser
der begehrte Wasserstoff gewonnen.
Dafür wird viel Strom benötigt.
Wir leben hier im Netzengpassgebiet.
Das heißt, Windstrom wird hier abgeschaltet.
Das heißt, wir haben Überschussstrom.
Und da war die Idee:
Was fangen wir mit dem Strom an?
Wir wollen ihn nicht wegwerfen.
Und die eine Idee ist,
in dieser Stromüberschusszeit
diesen Strom zwischenzuspeichern
und dann zu nutzen,
wenn er nicht … wenn die erneuerbare
Energie nicht direkt vorhanden ist,
und darüber hinaus dann
Anwendungen zu finden,
dass wir die Energie nicht nur wieder
ins Stromnetz zurückgeben,
sondern in die anderen Sektoren
wie Mobilität und auch Wärme.
Und so wird’s gemacht:
Mithilfe des Windstroms wird Wasserstoff aus
gereinigtem Leitungswasser abgespaltet.
Der wird dann zu den örtlichen
Wasserstofftankstellen transportiert.
Bei der Wasserstoffgewinnung
entsteht viel Wärme.
Diese wird ins örtliche
Fernwärmenetz geleitet,
so werden Häuser C02-neutral beheizt,
und zwar die im nahegelegenen Dorf Bosbüll.
Max Böhm profitiert davon.
Bislang gebe es keine Probleme damit,
meint der Handwerker.
Die Wärme ist jetzt ein Anfang
mit dem Gesamtprojekt …
natürlich auch in Bezug auf die Busse
[ist das] auch ein Anfang.
Schön wäre es natürlich,
wenn auch hier einfach
ein oder zwei Wasserstoffautos
vor der Tür stehen würden.
Das ist momentan preislich noch nicht so,
dass sich jeder das leisten kann oder
dass auch wir uns das leisten können.
Aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass das schon Zukunft hat, definitiv.
Ein Wasserstoffauto kostet ungefähr doppelt
so viel wie ein vergleichbares Dieselmodell.
Deshalb fahren erst 30 Stück in der Region.
Auch das Tanken ist teurer.
Für 500 Kilometer sind 50 Euro fällig,
während es beim Diesel 47 sind
und beim Elektroauto 25 Euro.
Also, wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen,
dass eine klimaschutzorientierte Wirtschaft
teurer ist als eine fossilorientierte Wirtschaft.
Das heißt Klimaschutz:
Und da sind wir ja alle daran interessiert,
dass wir unsere Welt retten.
Und wir sind jetzt am Anfang hier einer
Technologie, die es schon lange gibt,
aber die es halt noch nicht im Masseneinsatz
in der Form gab und gibt
und die durch den Masseneinsatz
aber auch günstiger wird.
Schon in wenigen Jahren
könnte die klimafreundliche Energienutzung
genauso teuer sein wie die herkömmliche,
so glauben sie hier.
Die Beispiele zeigen, dass die angewandte
Technik bereits alltagstauglich ist.